hey dr. Burke here I'm going to give you
a tip on fat burning how to lose the
maximum fat in the minimum time alright
there's three things that you can do to
keep it really really simple now these
are the doing misses of of things now
you might have a very sluggish
metabolism and we may need to get you
healthier to receive these messages
these fat burning signals so you don't
have this situation where you're like
burned bad I'm sorry did you say
something so but these are things that
you can do if your metabolism is
somewhat okay all right this insulin has
to be zero in the body now what does
that mean it means that insulin is the
hormone that's activated by sugars
here's the thing in the presence of
insulin even a little bit you will not
be able to burn fat even a little bit
especially if your metabolic rate is low
so you really have to not follow the
principle like everything in moderation
or you have to like really go down on
any types of breads pasta cereal
crackers viscous waffles pancakes
muffins sodas juice alcohol all those
hidden carbohydrates have to be 0 ok you
can't even have a little bit even fruit
may slow you down alright that's number
one I mean you should just try it for a
couple days and just see how it works
because you'll be surprised how much
weight a more weight you can lose now
cortisol has to be zero what does course
oh it's a stress hormone made by your
adrenal hormones I mean your adrenal
gland that has to be closed down to zero
as well it can't be too high so yes we
can work on the adrenals and do all
these things but as far as things that
you can do you need to go for a long
walks about 45 minutes sometimes to an
hour a day not power walking kind of a
nice easy pace so you're not strained
that is effective in lowering cortisol
especially if you have belly fat the
best workout for belly fat is walking ok
now with your headphones just get out
there in nature and walk secondly I want
you to get an extra hour of sleep yeah
get a little bit more sleep every day go
to bed a little earlier sleep in a
little long
take more naps on the weekend why
because sleep lowers cortisol those are
two big tips the third tip is to take
celery before bed four stalks of celery
that would be your snack maybe a little
peanut butter or something maybe he's
little hummus right before you go to bed
celery does help lower stress
it also helps lower blood pressure the
third tip no bloating you can't have you
can't be eating foods that bloat you and
still lose weight because this is a
stress so make sure the foods that you
eat even vegetables make sure that none
of it gives you gas and bloating and
constipation find the vegetables that
don't bloat you you know don't have the
beans whatever and make sure that
there's no digestive stress because this
can be another hidden barrier to losing
the weight so if these are the probably
the most powerful things to lose the
most fat in the minimum time